foreign
this is the special edition of your
money briefing for Friday April 28th I'm
J.R Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
welcome to the fifth and final episode
of our special series under contract
your guide to home buying today we're
focusing on the psychology of buying a
house there's just a certain warm
feeling about being home you hear it all
the time there's no place like home
there's no place like home
house
[Music]
when I think of home I think of a place
where there's
love overflowing in the Broadway classic
The Wiz Diana Ross yearns for the
feeling of the comfort and safety of
home those emotions often Drive
prospective home buyers through the
process of Landing the house of their
dreams
but the wistful romance and the
Nostalgia of Home can make them lose
focus and pursue a new home for the
wrong reason there's some sort of
synonymous relationship between buying a
home and sort of being the first rite of
passage for a married couple or a couple
starting out in life we feel the white
picket fence the house at the yard the
baby in its own Nursery is where we
should be going when we're younger and
starting out and sometimes that's not
always the best decision
over the past month we've talked a lot
about how to buy a house and if there's
one message underlying all those
conversations it's that buying a home is
a lot is creating a budget thumbing
through dozens maybe hundreds of
listings finding a real estate
professional getting the best mortgage
rate that can all help you land the
house of your dreams but the home buying
process really succeeds and fails in
your head so how does psychology play a
role in the home buying process I'm
joined by Financial psychologist and
author Dr Brad klontz who spent the last
20 years studying what we do around
money
so Brad this is one of the biggest
expenses someone will take on in their
lives and as we've heard in the previous
episodes in our series it requires
meticulous planning what causes people
to often enter the home buying process
with less than a sharp mind well first
of all we're wired to do it all wrong so
when we see a group of people doing one
thing we have a panic response a
survival response so we're very very
inspired to do the same thing whether
it's good or bad when it comes to
finances and then add on that our own
individual Financial psychology that we
got from our parents from our
grandparents we develop beliefs around
money which in our studies we call Money
scripts and these beliefs have a
profound impact on our spending
decisions and basically all aspects of
our relationship with money and these
beliefs we also inherit have to do with
home ownership so what did your parents
teach you what did they tell you about
whether you should own a home or not own
a home and because these things have a
profound impact on us and they can be
pass down through the generation so I'd
be curious about what your grandparents
thought about home ownership because
these beliefs will set you up
emotionally to decide whether you're
doing the right thing in life around
money or you're not or you're missing
out based on those beliefs on those
early messages we get around home
ownership we heard in last week's
episode that people sometimes enter the
housing market at the wrong time how
does psychology work into that well one
of the things that happens in just about
every area of investing or purchasing
decisions is fomo fear of missing out
this is hardwired into our brains we saw
this back in 2008 where people were
doing what in retrospect seem like crazy
behaviors they were doing all sorts of
things that in normal times you wouldn't
even consider doing because they saw
other people buying homes we saw this
happen with cryptocurrency too where all
of a sudden people are engaging in these
behaviors that didn't make a lot of
sense and it comes down to our wiring to
our ancestors being left behind meant
that you were going to die so
essentially if the tribe is moving in
One Direction and you're standing still
you got picked off by a predator or by
an enemy from another tribe and so it's
really really difficult to sit still and
to think rationally when two or three of
our friends are buying homes we start to
feel like we're being left behind and it
creates this existential anxiety and as
I said it feels like from your brain
from your emotional level it feels like
I'm going to die if I keep renting which
sounds ridiculous but that's what
happens at that deep emotional level so
what can people do to break free of the
grip that fomo and other psychological
hurdles are placing on their ability to
think rationally in this home buying
process well when it comes to all of our
financial decisions my best advice is
for you not to trust your instincts to
just accept the idea that we're all kind
of crazy when it comes to money and so
having some curiosity about whatever it
is if you have a sudden desire or you
feel this urgent need to buy a home you
want to engage your prefrontal cortex
because what's happening is it's
emotional you're seeing this happen
around you and interest rates are going
up I'm starting to get anxious should I
buy now because they're going to go up
even more take some time to self-reflect
on what's happening because when we
become emotionally charged we become
rationally challenged and the more
emotionally charged we are the more
likely we are to make a mistake so once
you've done that it's really important
to get an objective analysis to help you
decide whether this is a good financial
decision so bring in someone who isn't
as emotionally charged who isn't as tied
into your buying decision oh bringing
somebody completely from the outside
who's not with you in this home buying
Journey exactly it does help to have
somebody who also isn't necessarily
getting a commission for the sale but
find somebody who's objective to look at
like for example how long are you going
to own the home is it a good time to buy
now or is it not quite often whether
it's a good time to buy or not has more
to do with our individual financial
planning goals than it does with what's
happening in the market which is always
going up or going down when we can't
predict the future and then exam in your
beliefs what is your psychology around
home ownership in general like what are
your beliefs like some people have
beliefs that well homes never lose value
or real estate always goes up and
historically you might be correct but
that does not mean that it is the right
time for you to buy
so what's it like for home buyers who
have to deal with these emotional
hurdles on top of everything else
buying a home requires lots of brain
power but it's got to be the right brain
power letting the emotional side of your
brain call too many of the shots can get
in the way while you're dealing with all
the numbers all the phone calls all the
inspections and everything moving at a
frenetic Pace as you compete with other
buyers 44 year old Aseem geneja had to
navigate that Journey when he and his
wife bought a home in Massachusetts
frankly I wish there was like a crystal
ball for event to buy and I wish I had
known then at that point of Time how the
Market's gonna go up or down or if the
interest rates are going to go up or
down you make one of the biggest
investments in your life and you don't
really have a lot of specific data
customized for you that can help you
come up with the decision I wish I had
known this at that point of time tell me
about the mindset and the emotions that
you and your wife were dealing with when
you were in the buying process
yeah our mindset was you look at a house
as an example and then you really like
it and you want to make an offer but by
the time you come up with a decision to
make an offer say in the next 24 hours
the seller says they've already accepted
an offer so the mindset is a lot of
emotional up and down you want to find
the right place for yourself for your
family to grow in and to live in and you
get like a few hours to make a decision
and that's not easy right you have a
checklist you go through it you're like
okay halves must-haves good to haves and
then by the time you're done with the
decision making you call the seller or
your realtor and say look we are ready
to make an offer and then they call the
seller's realtor and they're like boops
house is sold gone offer accepted and
then you do it again next weekend you go
to another open house or you schedule a
showing specifically for yourself you
like the house or you don't like the
house if you don't like the house do it
again it's a Non-Stop rinse and repeat
process where you are falling short due
to time maybe due to not paying the
highest bid but you keep losing a lot of
the time before you get lucky I guess
dealing with the pressure to buy a home
and managing all the numbers and
decisions can throw prospective buyers
off their game and leave them to making
poor decisions wheelchair Tracy
McLaughlin has been selling houses in
California and Colorado for more than 20
years and she makes a point of educating
buyers on the role that emotions and
biases play as she's helping them
through the process
unlike any other asset that we possess
if you own an apartment building where
you have tenants or you've got a
commercial building or you have a stock
portfolio there's a very unique aspect
to residential real estate in terms of
it being an asset because it's where we
make our memories our home is where
we've made memories it's where we've
celebrated occasions it's where we have
had babies brought home so the
attachment to that asset from an emotive
standpoint supersedes any other asset
that I'm aware of and for that reason
tends to create stumbling blocks for
people when they make decisions so where
do you see this manifesting itself with
the buyers that you're bringing around
to see houses first time buyers they
have their eyes wide open right this is
such an exciting seminal time in their
lives when they're buying their first
home oftentimes they've just gotten
married or made a commitment or they're
thinking about a family and so there can
be in my opinion a lack of real due
diligence on the part of of younger
buyers in terms of making the absolute
best decision from both a lifestyle
standpoint and an investment standpoint
so while younger buyers unlike 20 years
ago have access to all sorts of data and
information they didn't used to have
because of our iPhones and Zillow and
all sorts of immediate data releases the
reality is they still need a lot of
coaching in terms of why house a is a
better investment than house B even
though house B can sometimes be more
appealing and that's where you get into
the nuances of this how does the lack of
clear thinking cloud people's ability to
think about options they might have
instead of buying a house well I think
we especially in the United States
there's some sort of synonymous
relationship between buying a home as
sort of for being the first rite of
passage for a married couple or a couple
starting out in life as partners Etc you
know there's a bit of a sensitivity to
being a quote failure if you're renting
versus owning now I think that has a lot
to do with market dynamics and where we
live but in general we feel the white
picket fence the house with the yard the
baby in its own Nursery is where we
should be going when we're younger and
starting out and sometimes that's not
always the best decision if you get the
best accountant available in your budget
you sit down and you really do the math
on taxes Insurance maintenance HOA fees
all sorts of ancillary expenses
gardening all sorts of things people
don't anticipate it might sometimes be
better to rent than to own especially if
it's a short-term plan for a couple and
there's probably strong feelings of
elation and anticipation as they cross
steps off their list towards securing a
home but where do you suggest that
people you know tap the brakes and take
a dose of reality I often advise
first-time home buyers actually any
buyers whether you're a subsequent buyer
but any first-time home buyer young
buyer or if someone's moving into a new
region in an area of what they're on
familiar with to actually do the leg
work and get in the car and drive over
multiple times visit the neighborhood
three times during the day what's the
Morning Light like what's the afternoon
like when does it actually get dark on
which side of the street perhaps that's
too much Northern Exposure for you and
you actually don't want to live in the
shade starting at two o'clock in the
afternoon in the winter so checking out
environmental concerns like how much
sunlight if there's ambient noise there
can be a lot of ambient bounce up noise
off of roadways into places in the Hills
that you would not anticipate and when
does that noise come and go things like
power lines those are huge inhibitors
for resale value and oftentimes they can
be in the view of a home and they'll
actually end up compromising the overall
Equity that you make when you go ahead
and sell your home so I'm a big fan of
driving over parking your car walking
the neighborhood multiple times a day
and talk to the neighbors the neighbors
will tell you what they love about
living there they'll also tell you about
what they don't like about living there
or if there's concerns about anybody or
any kind of intrusive noise or dog that
barks incessantly and nobody can make
that stop these are questions you
absolutely want to know what you're
getting on the other side when your
offer is accepted
[Music]
throughout the series we've learned that
buying a home is a lot more than just
relying on the old adage location
location
it requires knowing what you can afford
before starting your search
understanding the current housing market
and knowing where to find the best
mortgage rate and while understanding
the blizzard of numbers is in itself a
big hurdle having a clear mind and
avoiding mistakes can clear the path to
closing the deal and settling into your
new home
thanks for listening to episode 5 of
under contract your guide to home buying
and that's it for your money briefing
this week we'll be back on Monday with
more career and personal finance stories
our producer is mohsin Ali this episode
was mixed by Jess Fenton our supervising
producer is Melanie Roy and our
executive producer is Chris zinsley I'm
your host J.R Whalen thanks for
listening and have a great weekend
[Music]